et si vous dansiez comme au xviiie
siècle cette semaine le rendez vous des
juniors vous emmène en pleine période
baroque une période artistique
on prend notre machine à remonter le
temps qu'a mis parce que je propose
qu'on parte jusqu'au xviie siècle l'a
cette fois en 1600 c'est le début de la
période baroque une époque où de grands
noms ont marqué la culture comme jean
baptiste lully molière jean sébastien
bach deux siècles d'histoire à vivre aux
prises maëlan court puisque l'après midi
commence dès 15 heures et vous avez
rendez vous avec olivier y aurait un
danseur professionnel
l'idée c'est de faire sous la forme d'un
bal une initiation à ce qu'on appelle la
belle danse dont quand on parle de la
belle danse et la danse qui danse à la
cour du roi à la fin du xviie siècle il
c'est une danse qui empruntent et
d'opulence et les nobles à la cour et
qui empruntait beaucoup à toutes les
danses populaires et régional de
l'époque mais en les rendant plus
élégante plus gracieuse voilà et c'était
vraiment très important dans la vie
sociale et artistique de l'époque un
début d'après midi pour découvrir la
bourre et la sarabande ou la gavotte et
pour rendre le voyage dans le passé
encore plus réel le prisme vous invite à
venir à déguiser et qui dit époque
baroque et dit surtout prince c'est un
goûter dans une robe de bal avant la
dernière étape
un spectacle une pièce de théâtre aussi
tout droit venu du 17e siècle que
pourtant connaît bien
je suis sûr qu'à me que c'est votre
dessin animé préféré la belle au bois
dormant
alors là c'est la fabrique à théâtre qui
va le présenter et si on connaît bien
nous le film de 1959 celui proposé au
prisme lui vient des comptes du temps
passé du recueil de ma mère l'oie dans
une mise en scène surprenante et côté on
est un éclairage à la bougie donc la
suivante si vous venez samedi aux prises
n'y aura aucun éclairage électrique
on est sur une gestuelle très
chorégraphique comme c'était le cas à
l'époque sur c'est une pièce en ancien
français avec des costumes d'époque
alors la pièce elle commence à 17 heures
pour le bal c'est sur inscription à
l'adresse mac qui s'inscrit au bas de
l'écran il ya aussi un numéro de
téléphone
mais attention pour pouvoir apprendre à
danser comme xviiie siècle il faut aussi
assister au spectacle la belle au bois
dormant et donc à voir ces places une
après-midi historique à vivre dès l'âge
de 5 ans merci manuel on a reparlé de ce
rendez-vous au prix c'est pour vous
répondront dessins animés préférés c'est
plutôt le roi lion donc j'attends une
prochaine chronique dans la savane race
il existe un compte dans les savanes qui
vous y avoir prochainement c'est